[Music]
Janelle and Cody Brown back together
again but it's not what you think it
took a lot of work for us to figure out
how to navigate it the estranged spouse
is reunited to celebrate their youngest
daughter Savannah's High School
graduation Janelle sharing this rare
snap of Cody posing with The Graduate
all smiles on Savannah's big day it's
taken all of us to create the world
we're in
and so if it's good then we can give
ourselves credit there's also this sweet
photo of Savannah with her mom Brothers
Gabriel and Garrison and sister
Gwendolyn the daughter of Cody and his
ex Christine Janelle's cool as hell
Janelle writes in the caption Savannah
has graduated my children are all grown
up such a beautiful day but get this
Janelle cryptically adds there was
definitely a difference with this
graduation versus others in the past but
all is well in our lives we sit here by
consent being a family agreeing to work
things out together Janelle and Cody's
reunion comes nearly six months after
they confirmed their spiritual marriage
was over after 29 years we've been
separated for several months what
so are you separated yes we're separated
the lead up to it played out last season
on Sister Wives the last few years I've
begun to wonder
if we're compatible anymore maybe this
doesn't
work anymore for me I don't know maybe
this is not a good fit maybe this
doesn't work it's easy to start pointing
the other ugly finger to blame
and so no I don't just blame myself
but I do believe that as we go through
struggles there's always plenty of blame
to spread around since then Janelle's
been on a health kick doing something
kind of physical with your body
it's empowering and it makes it feel
like all is right with the world as for
Cody well he's largely stayed out of the
spotlight since the season ended but
when fans last heard from him on the
series's one-on-one special he was
optimistic about working things out I
hope I find it happy and and uh
beautiful place with Janelle and um I
hope all my kids and I can reconcile but
for Janelle their split is a done deal
I'm not waiting for him
I've kind of mourned that that part of
our life has gone I think it could be
there but it would require so much
change on both our parts that I don't
know so the door is still open
it has to be but I'm not interested in
having anyone walk through that door
this is an experience for me that is my
life and I'm kind of bearing my guts and
I know I feel like my job
is to be truthful and as kind as I can
be while being truthful one thing's for
sure Janelle and Cody can clearly put
their issues aside to celebrate their
kids
[Music]